so you all remember connor murphy from
the you know when he used to go to 6th
street in austin and take off his shirt
and girls would go holy [ __ ] he's got 19
abs
right and that was a schtick he was a
bodybuilder that was his thing
and then i think we touched on it
briefly when he
kind of got weirdly spiritual i think he
just did shrooms or acid
for the first time and like unlocked a
part of his mind that he didn't know
existed because he was like just like a
you know bodybuilding kind of i don't
know like meathead before yeah and now
he was like holy [ __ ] i'm actually like
this creative guy and i believe in god
and all this [ __ ] right
so that's what he
okay so that's like kind of a transition
he made so this is him before right he's
jacked as [ __ ] and he's just like posing
like as a
you know like it's a computer programmer
yeah exactly that's his computer program
around no this is a future
gamer yeah that's what he's posed as
right here right he's you know doing the
poses he's
i teach yeah this is all like the
physique of like i.t professional
uh devops senior back-end developer you
know just
game designer yeah um
look at the difference here this is
april 29 2020 right this is
last pick of me before the gym's closed
and then this is him
a month later
it feels good to be back in the real
world for those who didn't know a few
weeks ago i made a video where it
appeared i was going to harm myself
after that video i was arrested and
spent over two weeks in a psych ward
i just recently got out and feel amazing
just released a youtube video explaining
everything oh [ __ ] i didn't know that
holy [ __ ] also i
i apologize if i haven't sponder
responded your messages blah blah blah
okay so
he i don't know something happened to
him going to a psych ward is no joke man
i mean did what how does that happen
that had to have been induced by
something right
i'm not a substance or something like
that yeah i'm not even gonna speculate
i mean it's fine to speculate like i
don't do episodes like that just
randomly happen
i don't know i just don't like how do
you unlock yeah i mean i don't know
i don't want to say anything to be a
dick like i don't know what what
you know sent him in there you know i
mean anyway so then he became spiritual
and look at how much weight he lost here
he did a 40-day fast on food
he does not look right man holy [ __ ] he
lost
42 pounds in 40 days he didn't eat
anything for
40 days and the craziest part about it
is that
now he's like a yoga teacher and he
invented this
he invented this whole genre of yoga
where you
sit really closely with the woman and
you breathe
and you breathe and rub each other's
backs
[Music]
you know if you're going to start us you
know
i i guess you look at the group one the
group meditations look insane
oh music
i'm sorry the girl in the red does not
look into it at all it's
[ __ ] ridiculous man
the three of them this is the start of
the vr porn i watched
yeah you were conor murphy
holy son of a [ __ ] man
oh my god music no top middle top middle
is the wave
there here we go we can hear them
breathe
these are his meet and greets
you just get to sit on connor murphy's
lap and breathe
go to top middle you're missing the best
oh my god dude
i gotta pause it because there's music
what the [ __ ]
like
[Music]
a pr prima sati yoga sublimation
technique known as the breath treatment
keep in mind he made up
prima santi yoga premasati i don't even
know how to pronounce it premasati yoga
sublimation technique known as the
breath tracing headstand
in pramasti yoga sublimation is the
transfer of energy from your
penis to a woman's mouth
okay it doesn't say that it says lower
chakras to your higher chakras
oh wait this energy can be transferred
to your third eye chakra and help
activate
your penal glands your
your penal nice dude
it's the pineal gland dude have you
listened to joe rogan ever
are we going to become joe rogan if you
don't even know what the pineal gland is
you're just going to make these [ __ ]
three-year-old jokes about penal claim
cody come on it said penal gland man his
dick's in her face
what do you want me to do what do you
want me to say there this is clearly
sex with clothes on
we're not gonna be joe rogan if you just
see everything as sex okay
we need to start to train our minds
see a different point of view like i
would see how this
i could see how this would work maybe
like for couples
totally like you're this girl's like
literally sitting on him like this and
they're super close
yeah you can't tell me that's only
meditative
but he's doing it with like different
girls every time it kind of seems like
it's maybe like a
i don't know let's just you know what we
should wait until he buys a plot of land
in oregon
and and starts a colony yeah exactly and
we should go pay to live there and then
see if that's what it's all about
we can let our wives tell us exactly how
it feels
when we bring them there for them to
fall in love with him
hey if he's in a better if he's in a
better healthier mental state
then maybe it's good but this looks very
sketchy to me
as long as no one's paying to do that
you know i think that
it probably probably is charging for it
let's go let's find out here we go look
at
it
oh whoa he's got an only fans
yeah look at this exclusive spiritual
content
okay what is
what's the exclusive content it's on
patreon
he's got a spiritual enlightenment
channel
i would like to believe
how psychic powers work why am i posting
this video
well if you have not seen i just post a
video on my main channel
where i predicted the big
event that happened christmas morning i
predicted it back on december 12th
and it ended up coming true christmas
morning what happened
yeah can we get a oh the nashville
christmas oh
come on man oh god damn okay come on man
this is [ __ ] weird i'm getting out of
this we're gonna stop talking about this
because i don't like this at all
anyways i thought you guys would want an
update on bro what's going on with him
all right all right
oh my god whoo that that one hit me in
the [ __ ]
what
how you gonna make oh my
the pride in that one i predicted it i
told you it was gonna happen was it you
like yeah homie was it does the fbi know
you made that video
cia whoever handles that fda
fda crossfit you know
uh police division i don't [ __ ] know